what made you care about this how did
you get into this whole
universe you know i did anesthesia for
quite some time and
i and you're a real doctor then yeah
yeah i have an md um and um
i saw ketamine work pretty well and
because i was i did anesthesia right
was that fondue and anesthesia it was
interesting it was fun
and it was crazy and it was but it was a
you know i mean
would you listen to music and stuff
where you go in there nothing like that
you know we had
actually we had a surgeon who who would
get noise complaints from the other ors
because he would listen to death metal
all day and he would turn it up all the
way
and so he sort of had like a his own
little crew because
you kind of have to be like the right be
in the right mindscape to go in there
and listen to
mega death for 12 hours yeah at you know
80 db all day long yeah that's crazy
you're cracking up in a rib cage and
you're hot
all hopped up the surgeon's next door in
the room's next door would complain
you know it's like being in a hotel
they'd be like dude tell them to knock
it off
but it was i mean it was it was it was
crazy
i mean it was good but it was it was
like
super busy super high intensity yeah um
and you have to stay the whole time you
just hit them with that dose and you
roll out
it depends okay but the way our model
was we had
uh nurse anesthetists and
and so we would we worked together with
them and they would stay the whole time
and i would i would come in and
troubleshoot things and get the
get the ball rolling and and you know we
were at a place where we
we took care of really sick people so it
was um
you know it was but you sort of
acclimate to it and then you look around
and you look at what you acclimated to
and uh but but for me what what got me
turned into the corner of this is is um
sort of my understanding of suffering
has evolved a lot
and um
i had a brother and he died last year
he was injured as a child
terribly and he never
could get the help he needed and so he
he did a lot of drugs he
tried to take his own life several times
oh man it's hard to hear that
he did all these things and and i was
sitting there and
and he knew he was dying he was in
hospice but
i was you know looking at what was
coming down the pipeline i was like you
know if
if we can help people who've been
traumatized
like it's sort of like for me it's like
if this would have been around 20 years
ago maybe i'd still have a brother ah
because he he was sexually abused as a
kid
and did never tell anybody nobody
the only reason we found out about it is
because our
our pastor was imprisoned after the fact
by somebody else
dang and so i couldn't figure out what
was wrong with him his whole life
and i i asked him one night and he goes
yep and i was like [ __ ]
and but the damage was just
like yeah how much that shaped somebody
that's young that's man that's
heartbreaking i'm sorry
yeah so and i'm sorry for him i'm sorry
that you know it's heartbreaking to see
you know i've been
you know a lot of my family and being in
recovery and struggling through those
you know struggling through trauma and
stuff like that childhood trauma not
like that
uh but different types of trauma and
stuff has been pretty prevalent in my
family and
it's heartbreaking to see the effect
that it has on people you know
it it was you know the last six months
of his life i i finally got him to say
because he was like he was a he was a
crusty guy
was he yeah yeah and uh the last were
you guys pretty close
yeah oh that's cool and he knew he was
he knew he was dying
was he drinking himself to death yeah he
did he had the operations and
and he kind of stopped
actually but the problem was is the
damage was done and
and but like you know one of the last
times we
we spoke um i was sitting with him in
the hospital he was on hospice and
and for the last six months of his life
i got him to tell me that
i told him i loved him every day and he
was like i love you too
and like just for him to be able to
express emotion was priceless
yeah and then you know when the last
moments we spoke i said i love you and
he said he'd love you
i love you too and then he goes and he
flips me the bird and i was like that's
that's mike and uh and so it was like
you know i
he knew at least he was loved yeah and
and um that was in um it's important
yeah i think a lot of people's life if
they struggle with trauma i think some
of it is just yeah
thinking that people don't care people
that think unable to feel love it's
weird how a traumatic event can block
off other things you know
yeah he couldn't he he didn't have the
capacity
and he never so he he was
stuck and he could never get out of it
and you kind of wonder
or hope that if somebody else comes to
me
and a little younger and hasn't burned
themselves
physically like like damaged themselves
enough that you can help them turn the
corner
yeah and get healing going in a way that
they they can get back on the road of
life and
and that's sort of that's
to me is a very rewarding way to
interacting with life you know i can
look over my shoulder and be like
i am okay with what i'm doing i'm
helping people
find peace right
yeah it's it man it's so fascinating how
like if you ca if you don't feel
loved or if something makes you feel so
unloved or so damaged that then you
it's very hard to feel love after that
because i think there's just
receptors in you that just do not trust
it or just do not trust the world
almost in a weird way and i don't even
think you can access it sometimes
like that's the that's the such hard
thing is to be able to access
why or what or how to change it to get
the clay in your hands
you know it feels like you just
can't find it you know um so it's
fascinating to hear that there's
opportunities that this could be a way
where people can
i'm i'm you believe it i believe it
i do i really do because um i've seen it
work i've seen it work
on a lot of people and it it's one of
those things where
it's it's like you get to see these
people come to you and they're just
broken
and and the first time you hear them
laugh
and or smile and you're just like it
it's it it's
i'm in the right place yeah
that's fascinating man hope you enjoyed
that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one
you